[Music]
in this video we will talk about the
various regions of the abdomen now this
will be a part one of the two-part
series of the videos in the second video
we will discuss the organs present in
the respective regions of the abdomen
and also we will talk about the
differential diagnosis of the pain which
is referred to these regions and these
are the two clavicles and below these
are the two inguinal ligament s' on the
medial side they are attached to the
pubic tubercle on the pubic bone and
these two pubic bones are joined by the
pubic symphysis
and the lateral attachment of the
inguinal ligament is to the anterior
superior iliac spine one thing I want to
mention here is the difference between
the middling Whannell point versus the
midpoint of the inguinal ligament the
distance between anterior superior iliac
spine and pubic tubercle is traversed by
the inguinal ligament and the middle of
this ligament is known as the midpoint
of the inguinal ligament but there is
another distance which is present
between the anterior superior iliac
spine to the pubic symphysis and the
middle point of this distance is known
as the middle anal point and this is one
of the reference points for dividing the
abdomen into various regions so to
divide the abdomen into various regions
we take four lines two of them are
vertical above these lines pass through
the mid clavicular point and below the
pass through the middle anal point not
the midpoint of inguinal ligament there
are two horizontal lines which are used
in dividing the abdomen into various
regions the first of them is the
subcostal plane now these this plane
passes through the lower most part on
the ribcage that corresponds to the 10th
ghazal cartilage and posteriorly it
corresponds to a third lumbar vertebra
or the l3 now the second
in plane we use is the trans tubercular
plane now this plane passes through the
two tubercles on the iliac crest and
here early and posteriorly it
corresponds to the fifth lumbar vertebra
a first we will talk about the three
regions in the middle of the abdomen the
first of them is the epigastric region
or the epigastrium now since this region
lies just above the stomach it is known
as the EPI gas trium and the area just
below the epigastrium is the unlike el
region since this region corresponds to
the unlike us on the abdomen it is known
as the unlike occult region and the area
just below them like a region is the
hypogastric or the suprapubic region
since this lysis above to the pubic
bones it is known as suprapubic and also
it lies below the stomach it is known as
the hypogastric region and the areas on
the either side of the epigastrium are
the hypochondriac regions on the left
side this is the left hypochondriac
region since this region corresponds
just below the costal cartilages it is
known as the hypochondriac region on the
opposite side this is the right
hypochondriac region now the two regions
only opposite sides of the unlike al are
the left lumbar and on the opposite side
it will be the right lumbar region since
these two regions lie just on the sides
of the lumbar spine they are named after
them as the lumbar regions and the lower
areas are the left iliac and the right
iliac regions since these lie just above
the iliac bones these are known as the
iliac regions so this was a short
description about how we divide the
abdomen into nine regions and the name
of those regions make sure to watch the
second part of this video in which we
will discuss the various organs present
in the respective regions of the abdomen
and also we will discuss the
differential diagnosis of the pain which
is referred to these regions make sure
to like and share this video and also if
you want to see more videos on this
channel make sure to subscribe thank you
so much for watching this video